I'm joined now by the former senior
Military Intelligence officer Philip
Ingram good to see you again Philip uh
now of course Russian forces have made
some advances in recent days in back
mood but on the whole there's been very
little movement on the front line in
recent weeks and months why is that yeah
well exactly yeah day 374 of Vladimir
Putin's 10-day special military
operation um and the Russians we keep
talking about this spring offensive
they're probing the front lines in
different places back mode will more
detail than that in a moment but further
north up around cremina and in the South
around Donetsk they're trying to see
where their weaknesses in the Ukrainian
defenses
um and they're not really finding any
the the things that are influencing at
the moment the weather the ground is
softening up it's difficult for armored
vehicles and armored permissions to
maneuver on it the Russians don't seem
to have been able to develop an armored
punch a big bit of combat par with these
Reserve forces at the moving round even
though there's some capability there so
we're watching for that closely and UK
defense intelligence today said once
again that they believe the Russians
were running out of ammunition and a
particular artillery ammunition which is
something they need a lot of and
something they've been using a lot yeah
sure and looking more closely at back
moot itself of course which has been
under Fierce fighting for months now how
close are we to seeing that fall to
Russian control that's a difficult one
you know the Russians have been
advancing um and trying to Circle it
from from the north and they're having
some small successes there and they're
coming in from the East as well
ukrainians have
carried out some actions by demolishing
a couple of bridges that would suggest
they're preparing to pull out but what
the ukrainians have been doing is
effectively fixing the Russians in place
and back mode for the last seven and a
half months and that's allowed them to
trip the Russians you know seven Russian
dead for every one Ukrainian according
to the Ukrainian Minister of Defense
um and also fix the Russians attention
in there not just pouring more troops in
but that then allows the ukrainians to
potentially prepare for something else
elsewhere and it also means that whilst
they're still holding on to back mood
the Russians can't then get their
artillery and everything else forward
and this is the level of Destruction
that we're singing backward and then
Focus out on the next town or the next
Village or the next city bakmut
originally 70 000 now between four and
four and a half thousand civilians in
there according to the deputy mayor this
is standard Russian tactics of destroy
the place with artillery and then flood
it with unprotected infantry to try and
get forward ukrainians are responding
with their artillery their armor and
elsewhere and that's why so many
Russians are getting killed now
obviously we've been hearing repeated
calls from Ukraine for more military
equipment from the from the west from
International Partners but you you
mentioned British intelligence uh in
your latest update how are we helping
them in terms of surveillance well the
British intelligence is part of a wider
International effort and if you go on to
some of the the the flight radar apps on
a daily basis you'll see these sorts of
things flying and these sorts of
patterns coming out and these are
aircraft that are coming in that are
intelligence surveillance under
reconnaissance aircraft that are
providing a number of different
intelligence outputs this is a British
rc-135
signals intelligence aircraft and the
Americans are a global hawk but we're
also getting aircraft coming in from you
know five or six different nations and
they're all providing three types of
intelligence signals intelligence and
Communications intelligence they're
hoovering everything up that the
Russians are saying and then analyzing
that measurement and signature
intelligence they're seeing what's on
the ground and they can see armored
vehicles they can see missiles being
launched they can see convoys that are
moving and analyze that and then imagery
intelligence and of course the sorts of
samples go from the drones that the
ukrainians have we saw those pictures
there to provide the intelligence
picture up to what can be provided from
satellites that is all being analyzed
and helping
um give the ukrainians more targeting
materials so they can understand where
the key places are to hit um within the
Russian forces okay Philip for now
thanks very much